even a global pandemic can't stop two of
tv's biggest reality shows from
returning this week
two of our favorites right nichelle
shark tank and amazing
i don't think people know how much we
like these shows yeah
jam for real now everybody may be
wondering because we were wondering how
can contestants race all around the
world and still stay safe
well it's all in the timing welcome to
the hollywood bowl
and the start of your amazing race
one of the great things about race
coming back is just to see the world
the way it was season 32 of the amazing
race premieres tonight
how they pull off those foreign taxi
rides wild physical challenges and a
massive celebration in the caribbean
during a pandemic
it was actually shot nearly two years
ago
no amazing race cast has ever had to
wait
so long to be able to now share secrets
that they want to share because they
have to wait till it goes to air
go so did the winner have to wait to get
their prize
till now they got to wait they got it
i mean you can't just go down to the
bank and say hey i got this big check i
want to cash
really where'd that check come from
meanwhile shark tank kicks off season 12
this friday on abc
the la based production crew moved to
the venetian resort in las vegas to
create their own
covet-free bubble i want to talk more
about these protocols
tell me everything we had to quarantine
for a period of time
get tested every third day we i mean
literally when we would walk to set they
had tape a specific
elevator hair makeup was in hazmat
so it was really it was completely
different everything social distancing
if anybody was uncomfortable about
anything
we would stop the entire production
until we sorted out there was no playing
around with this
the show will also look a little
different this season everybody is in a
big semi-circle
and you actually feel like you can have
a conversation it takes a pandemic
for innovation even in the shark tank i
like the fact that we don't need to
share
food with each other we can't because
cuban used to always
take all of my food